there is shock in Germany this morning
after shootings at two hookah lounges
left nine people dead in a town outside
Frankfurt authorities say they found the
43 year old alleged gunman and his 72
year old mother dead at his apartment
overnight Seth noan is in Hanau Germany
near one of those hookah lounges Seth
good morning these are pretty particular
targets what do we know about the
motivation in this case good morning to
you Tony that's right we are hearing
from federal prosecutors here who say
that they believe this alleged gunman
had extremist right-wing views and we
have reviewed a manifesto that was
rambling lengthy racist paranoid in
which he used terminology from the Nazi
era specifically talking about
purification in attacking what he called
ethnic groups and races that are
destructive in every sense there is
heavy police presence outside the
suspects home this morning or just a
short while ago they removed what's
believed to be his car the alleged
gunman attacked the two hookah lounges
in this Frankfort suburb it's believed
he opened fire at one of the cafes and
then sped off driving about a mile and a
half to where he targeted people in
another hookah lounge which was not far
from his house these cafes where patrons
smoke flavored tobacco from water pipes
are popular in the Middle East and Asia
and this morning police say some of the
victims were Turkish and Kurdish in
origin outside the arena cafe police
cordoned off a car that appeared to have
been hit by bullets
Taavi notes this witness whose father
and brother worked nearby likened it to
being in a film oh my god they were
horrified and crying he explained
everyone was shocked the sync this
whistle train you know I witness Enzo in
Grau described a scene of chaos bang
bang bang bang and everybody run I see
much panic panic
why do this why kill the people today
the German Chancellor condemned the
attack and pledged to work against those
who are trying to divide this country
along ethnic lines it is also worth
noting that the number of right-wing
extremists here in Germany jumped 30
percent up a third last year and the
number of attacks are up to Anthony Seth
Doane in Germany thank you